welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down the finale of 13
reasons why the Netflix phenomenon has
just dropped its final season and
throughout this video we'll be going
over everything you need to know about
it and it's ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the show yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and hopefully this video gives you 13
reasons why you should hit the thumbs up
button with that terrible pun out of the
way let's get into our breakdown of the
series
okay so season 3 pretty much centered
around the murder of Bryce Walker the
highly hated teen died a disgrace with
very few friends and because of this
everyone was a suspect we learned that
it was Alex that carried out the crime
but the season ended with the blame
being pointed towards Monty which
exonerated him completely throughout
season 4 this lies slowly unravels and
we pretty much watch as the truth slowly
comes to the surface so that the
characters can finally close the book on
it however this isn't the only closing
of the book and metaphorically season 4
culminates with the students leaving
high school and starting a new chapter
in their lives 13 reasons why the
matically has always been about choices
and how certain ones can have a
butterfly effect that ends up and things
spiraling out of control
season 4 exemplifies this with the
choices that the characters have made in
the prior three entries all having large
carryovers I'm going to be primarily
focusing on the arc of clay as the thing
that that has the most repercussions on
the others but there's just so many
things going on that I would of course
love to hear your favorite aspects of
the show from the off the season really
hammers home how difficult it can be for
some to survive high school the show
even opens with a line stating that some
people just don't make it and a big
death is teased with a funeral that
happens six months ahead of where the
majority of the season takes place now I
really think another major theme of 13
reasons why is that two wrongs don't
make a right
though Bryce was a terrible person the
murder of the character was also wrong
and thus the group had to deal with the
repercussions of it this culminates
throughout the season and the choices
they made a cover it up all have
devastating
nowhere is this more represented in clay
and the anxiety that he suffers with
throughout as someone who's dealt with
anxiety myself I found the portrayal of
very accurate though I haven't exactly
had the ghost of a person i frame
familiar haunting me overthinking things
and thus creating paranoia can often
happen it can send your body into weird
states such as agitation overheating and
just shutting down worrying is often an
overuse of your imagination and I love
that this season dealt with the inner
turmoil that clay was suffering with
because of all that he'd been through
whether it's the guns connected to Tyler
the cover-up being unearthed or just the
ghost of Monty that haunts him you
really see what is happening to him
mentally
the paranoia heightens when Winston
arrives at school and emboldened Clay's
mental illness as he believes the truth
will finally come out Winston was of
course the secret ex of Monty and he
knows he's innocent due to being with
him on the night of the murder he starts
to get closer to Alex and I actually
spent a lot of time wondering whether
his feelings were genuine or if he was
simply manipulating the character
someone starts to tone clay with strange
phone calls and he loses his grip on
reality in our eyes he becomes an
unreliable narrator as we as viewers
can't really distinguish what's real and
what isn't also is it just me or when
his phone was ringing did you start
shouting just pick it up man
first ring pick it up anyway the voice
tells him to do more and more things and
slowly it starts to escalate I was
convinced that this voice was penny wise
when they found blood in the shower but
it's revealed to just be Monty's
teammates they were pulling a prank but
because he freaks out they realize he's
hiding something darker a kind of jump
at a bear as I don't want to recap some
of the pointless elements of the season
but the paranoia within the character
slowly starts to come to the surface as
the ghost from his past get closer and
closer initially I did kind of feel that
this was a slightly slower season than
some of the prior entries as I didn't
think it had many big moments
early on however it quickly ramps up and
at just ten episodes as opposed to the
regular 13 it really feels like the big
moments start to come thick and fast
clay loses that B card a big crash
happens and the school goes into
lockdown with a suspected shooter this
is all revealed to be a drill for the
experience of its end
clay into a complete nervous breakdown
the blackout's hallucinations and
paranoia all hit a high point when both
visions of bryce and monte come to
torture him now these visions are really
important to note as clays mental health
issues eventually caused him to develop
dissociative personality disorder he
pretty much takes on a dual identity in
which a violent side of him begins to
subconsciously commit crimes that will
eventually unearth the truth and bring
to light the things that he has done
this revelation comes much later in the
season but watching certain elements
with the knowledge of how he develops
definitely needs to be kept in mind he
finally accepts culpability for it and
in facing his inner demons that have
manifested as the pair he realizes he
has to right the wrongs of his past his
mental health does to climb further in
the wake of the lockdown but due to the
support of his friends and family he's
able to reach a positive outcome Tyla is
revealed to be an informant for the
police that's been working with them in
the wake of the guns being discovered
and I think this reveals sort of
symbolizes the major theme towards the
ending of the season that is the future
and how we must always be mindful of it
but in doing so we must make sure we are
present in well the present clearly
Tyler was stuck in a corner with the
police and he found a way to navigate
towards the future still having it
intact by his choices clay however
continues to live in the past constantly
haunted by what he's done
which makes him no longer mindful of the
present or the future and thus he makes
brash mistakes his past literally
becomes a physical manifestation within
his personality in a way that it tries
to constantly bring the past to light so
that he can finally move on to the
future thinking about the series as a
whole thirteen reasons why is all about
how the past can always come back to
haunt you and it is rightfully be
mindful of the present so you can have a
future at a clay looked ahead rather
than always behind I think that some of
this season would have gone a different
way with him he would have not been
tortured by the apparitions that
seemingly stalked him and eventually
this led to him coming some truly
terrifying acts one of the only times
that we actually see clay thinking about
the future properly he doesn't actually
have a realistic grasp upon it and
instead imagines the air 2161 where the
earth is a polluted
and Phil under attack from a sentient
robot army that exists in the Andromeda
girl yeah its core completely crazy now
a great line that appears towards the
end of the season is that the best way
to fail is to have no plan at all and I
think that this is exemplified by clay
who's constantly trying to navigate the
past in order to ease his conscience
rather than thinking about how things
may play out he's brash impulsive and
acts on a whim without really thinking
of the repercussions and can cause
because deep down he wants it to come to
light by prom he does eventually get to
live in the moment but he definitely
spends most of his time buried in the
past this is mirrored by Tony who
initially doesn't think of how things
will go ahead but he does eventually
gain a big opportunity by changing his
focus school is all about preparing us
for the future
I think as a whole the show is pretty
much been about how he must constantly
be mindful of it all I can do far more
damage over time than the truth can and
I think that clay and coke could have
saved themselves a lot of pain
had they opened up earlier rather than
trying to cover things up however
another theme of the show is of course
unity and the group definitely managed
to get through things because of each
other
nowhere is this idea of taking a stand
shown more than in the walkout that
happens after some police brutality it's
obviously difficult to not draw
comparisons with real-world events right
now and though the show has always been
controversial this definitely feels like
it's come at the right time
clay states that they have to bring it
all down because he is merely a prisoner
of the structures that have been put in
place around him I think that his
personality is literally trying to bring
these walls down and that is why he
destroys the deans car again this is all
because of the repercussions of choices
early on that clay made and he was
unable to truly process the weight of
his actions
so his brain had to find a way to deal
with them every time the truth has
suggested is shot down when it could
have ultimately stopped so many more
lives from happening
the lies are reflected in the characters
parents as well who track their children
and I did appreciate how they were
initially trying to just keep their
children safe through a lie whilst claim
Coe were doing the same thing in order
to protect one another ultimately most
of the truth all comes out in the end
and this includes drug use sexuality and
more being talked about openly
the promises celebration of them finally
lifting the way of their shoulders way
you brought a hooker to problem anyway
clay embraces the moment and is finally
finally present in the present Winston
gets dense with Alex and it feels like a
certain sense of closure to me this
symbolizes all of the characters finally
letting go of the past and though it may
not have a literal sense to it it shows
the ending of the pain that the past has
caused all of the characters we all have
regrets from our lives but we have to
learn to live with them and move on much
like how the characters in the show do
they are progressing and whether it's to
prom kings a big twist with boundaries
and more this is about moving forward in
a positive direction this is 13 reasons
why though so of course the happiness
doesn't last long and Justin who's been
exhibiting flu-like symptoms throughout
the season is eventually diagnosed with
AIDS which would pass through drug use
and sex work there was a point in the
show that Justin and clay had to take
drug tests and the former blamed the
other for switching them to provide a
positive result he's revealed to be the
character that the funeral was held for
and it's honestly not something I was
expecting comes as a big blow and though
it's tragic it reminds us that we have
to make the most of what we have and the
time we do by being present in the
moment and appreciating all of it we
must take the good with the bad because
that's what makes life worth living
that's really the message that Justin
tries to pass on before his death and I
also think that it's the message that
the show is trying to portray high
school and life in general passes by in
the blink of an eye so make of it what
you can love what you have and and I'm a
crying you're crying
Justin's death finally makes clay and
the group appreciate all they've gone
through and it tells them to leave the
past in the past and focus on improving
themselves Alex also confesses Bryce's
murder to Winston and the latter hands
over the tape to the former which means
that Bryce can no longer ruin any more
lives he returns to taunt Jessica
mentally but she says that though Bryce
made the world a certain way they learn
to love each other by taking a negative
and turning it into a positive there's a
lot of scenes of closure and discussion
but you really feel like everyone is
grown in a positive way by
to accept how things are we've all made
mistakes as that therapist states and we
are guided onto the right path by others
just like how they were guided when they
were younger this sort of brings
everything to a close and he states that
he began much like how clay does after
closing the lid on what's happened to
him
Jessica admits that she was a one-issue
person but she shifted this to focusing
on love loving all that she has and all
that will happen to her
hate is too easy and it drove Bryce down
a dog path and almost took those around
him with him but they survived and
together the friends loving one another
or what got them through it
it shows us that you can survive
anything no matter how hard things are
and it's definitely a message that's
more important now than ever choose to
live choose to get through it because
there's always going to be something
worth living for even if you haven't
encountered it yet love the moment live
in the moment and enjoy it it's a
perfect way to end the show and watching
these characters say their goodbyes
after the four seasons that we've been
through really feels like the best
send-off they could get the group go
their separate ways on to their new
lives and the next chapter but they've
still in so much clay is even accepting
of his ghosts and though they've
tormented him he eventually learns that
the past is making him stronger and it's
not something that he should be driven
to hate you can find the love where you
look for it and forgiveness is always
something that you should have clay
finally accepts the ghost that has
driven him the most and that is Hannah
she returns for a final goodbye and it's
a I'm a swear I'm not I'm not crying he
says goodbye dare in some form just as
he meets someone new and they bury the
tapes along with the past at home he
reads a piece by Justin that reminds us
that the other is darkness the light
shines to move it all out the way and
this makes clay realize that though he
was a negative person he had a positive
influence much like how it's therapist
did on him though we don't know what
happens to the character after this he
will survive life is just a set of
chapters and through it all we have many
ups and downs but we can get through it
you take care
but that sounded really sad when I said
that out loud but it does close out the
season and as I'm sure you can guess
from the way that I've written this
review and delivered it it was a very
emotional ride that does feel like a
fitting farewell for one of Netflix's
biggest properties so that was 13
reasons why and after watching all of
the episodes in the same day I feel like
it was an incredible journey that felt
like the best send-off we could have
gotten I've had lots of highs lots of
lows and yeah what an amazing journey 13
reasons why was brilliant and I get a 9
out of 10 now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the season and what you
took from the ending comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please drop a thumbs up it makes
you check out our breakdown of defending
jacob which is gonna be linked at the
end we go over our interpretation of the
events so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you want to
support the channel from his letters at
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow said heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to give it a date with us so
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care
peace
[Music]